I'm giving you exactly what I would do
you have six clients paying you a
thousand you want all of them to get to
three four five thousand you take three
of them and you send them an email and
set up a phone call and you tell them I
want to give you as much time as
possible some might be expiring in two
months some might be three months if I'm
getting too much demand my business is
evolving I want to give you the preview
that's gonna be three thousand dollars a
month if you want to continue with me at
the end of the contract you know I
really appreciate you and so I want to
help you find someone else if that's not
in the cards but I'd love to continue to
work with you yeah no that makes sense I
feel like even my clients sometimes
they'll say they're not happy with me
but they continue to work with me
because clients rightfully because
they're doing what's right for their own
business sometimes will complain as
negotiation tactic you just have to get
in your mind that you're okay with
giving up these three thousand dollars a
month because you may lose them anyway
at the end but you're gonna learn a lot
from the process of telling three
clients you're going from a thousand to
four thousand